so we've had a lower decks strange new
ones cross over how about an Enterprise
Strange New World's crossover
Captain Archer could still return
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
so following the brilliant strange new
worlds and lower decks crossover this
rumor about Scott Bakula's Captain
Archer returning to Star Trek has been
mixed up once again I've read at least
two different articles suggesting that
this might be about to happen now where
is the logic in that the reason why well
it does seem that the nx01 really was a
central theme for that episode you know
it was the fact that the nx01 was made
out of that honorarium honorary honorary
room honorrhea
stuff that had a nice gray tint to it
um that was required to make the portal
work to send boyimla and Mariner home
Captain Archer was mentioned a couple of
times Captain Pike is a big fan
so that has got some people to stir up
this rumor once again that Scott Bakula
is planning to return to Star Trek
but
is it remotely true you have no idea how
much I'm restraining myself I'm knocking
you on your ass
well Scott Bakula is a fan of Star Trek
he has said in many interviews that he
would love to return if the right
storyline presented itself so from at
least that point of view it's possible
he as an actor has said he wouldn't mind
terribly strange new worlds has shown
that they're more than willing to take a
few risks and that actually a show where
they did jump back in time maybe and saw
the nx01 isn't out of the realm of
possibility and to be honest Star Trek
has done this loads of times before the
Deep Space Nine crew went back and saw
the Enterprise we saw flashbacks from
The Excelsior with Sulu and commanderies
we've seen that type of thing a few
times so possible the only thing with
that is though they would have to think
of maybe a different way to do it
because we've seen it before so what do
we actually know about Captain Archer
and Captain Pike exactly for example
when were they born when did they die
that sort of thing is there any
opportunity or any possibility that
these two characters could have met and
actually Scott Bakula's Captain Archer
appearing in strange new worlds could
maybe just be a flashback something
captain pike is thinking about in an
episode well Captain Archer was born in
2112 according to most of the bio stuff
we know about him um it's then believed
he died in 2245 this is based on Mike
susman's biography this was information
that was created and generated for
Enterprise but then was never actually
added to scream
so he died in 2245 born in 2112.
was born now if you think it's a little
bit fuzzy about when Captain Archer died
when captain pike was born is even more
fuzzy
um one data is 2205 another date though
has it that he took command of the
Enterprise in 2250 at the age of 38 that
would mean he was actually born in 2212.
um math is not my strong suit as as
regular side trackers no so we're just
going to say Pike was born in the early
23rd Century all right just leave it at
that
we believe he took command of the
Enterprise in 2250 he was roughly 38 40
years old roughly the same age that
actually
um Captain Archer was when he took
command of the nxl1 there was a century
between those two events by the way the
launch of the nx01 was 2151 and when
Pike took over the Enterprise was 22.50
so a century
but obviously
if Archer died in 2245
and Pike was born in 22 10 5 whatever
um obviously they existed they were
alive together for about 13 years
Archer only actually died five years
before Pike took over the Enterprise the
so
there is a possibility that they met now
I don't know any Canon that I'm aware of
that says they never met
now Pike didn't mention that he'd met
him when he was talking about how much
of a fan he was and how much he'd have
loved to have worked on the nx01
but that doesn't mean they didn't it
would have been a slightly odd thing for
Pike in that moment to have got I met
him he's great so Maybe
we also do obviously have the time
travel thing now this is normal for Star
Trek but we're assuming that would mean
Pike going back in time what if Archer
came forwards in time that is a
possibility now obviously Scott Bakula
is a few years older than he was back
then
um so it would be an older version of
Archer that we then got to see in
strange new worlds
but that's fine what we could also
obviously see though is some sort of
story where they don't actually meet the
Archer and Pike and the rest of the crew
from strange new worlds are in a story
that actually jumps backwards and
forwards there are events that are
happening to Archer in say 22 20 or 22
30 or something like that
that maybe causes a mystery or create
something or something happens that then
affects events in strange new worlds so
that we're actually seeing both stories
sort of intertwined together you know
she's jumping backwards and forwards so
there's no time travel Shenanigans
there's no you know temporal distortions
or temporal police knocking out or
anything like that none of none of that
stuff that we get to see and to be
honest we've probably seen enough in
already this series of strange new
worlds it could just be interesting
storytelling this happens this happens
they intertwine them together you know
they're flashbacks they are little they
clip the little bits together and
through the hour of the episode we get
to slowly see both parts of the story
come together and say the mystery gets
solved to Strange New worlds or
something else there are lots of ways
though to be honest that they could
bring Scott Bakula back into Star Trek
it's one of the beautiful things about
sci-fi is that anything is possible
but do I think it's likely well Scott
Bakula gets asked about it all the time
like I've said and he has said maybe
strange new worlds to show that they are
more than willing to take every risk
Under the Sun so maybe but let's be
honest
JJ Abram Star Trek and now new track
have always championed shows like
Enterprise Archer has been mentioned in
Discovery several times The Adventures
of the nxr one have been mentioned
throughout new track we saw a ship that
was very similar to the nx01 actually in
the last Star Trek movie they've
obviously thought it was important very
early on to actually Champion Star Trek
Enterprise we even see some of the time
travel Shenanigans getting mentioned in
Star Trek strange new worlds very
similar to what we saw in Enterprise
so it does seem the creators of strange
new worlds do feel an affinity with
Enterprise and maybe that will be the
main reason why they would love to see
Scott Bakula one of the most underrated
captains within Star Trek for me you
know it's always Picard and Kirk and
blah blah and Janeway even but actually
I loved Captain Archer and I loved Scott
Bakula as Captain Archer so final
question is would I like this to happen
yeah
I think Scott Bakula is one of those
just bullying actors I've loved him from
the quantum link days
I loved him in NCIS I loved him in
Enterprise as you guys know if you're a
regular side tracker I am infuriated
with Star Trek Enterprise at times I
don't hate it I don't dislike it I just
think it could have been even better
than it was I've always thought that it
should have explored the beginning of
the Federation far more than it explored
the temporal time War and the zindy war
and all that sort of thing I wanted to
see more Federation stuff do you
remember I told you about a federation
what about it
I work with some people who are going to
be pretty angry at me for telling you
this but you're going to be an integral
part of forming that Federation
but
I now look back on Star Trek Enterprise
and I still think it's got some of the
best crew some of the best actors I love
trip I love to Paul I loved all of those
characters to be honest
and I still think I think they put a lot
of really hard work into that show some
of the technology Etc was absolutely
spot on well placed for the time period
I loved some of the politics yeah okay
they got a few things wrong and I think
even the creators look back and say that
but they got an awful lot right and I
would love to see strange new worlds
tipping their hat to Enterprise an
Enterprise getting a little bit of the
Kudos it deserves but I'd love to know
exactly what you think do you want to
see Scott Bakula's Captain Archer
appearing in the new Strange New World
Series do you think there is a crossover
here and if so how would you do it get
into the comments and tell me exactly
what you think if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification that really helps us
out and you can follow all of these
links that have been scrolling across
the bottom they're all in the
description as well and as always please
stay safe I'll see you next time
[Music]
thank you